موسكو لا تلعب بالنار فنحن لم
ندخل مرحلة الجد بعد وما هذه الا
البداية. واسراب الموت الروسية
تغزو كييف والنتيجة كارثية.
بينما اكثر من خمسمائة واربعين
جنديا اوكرانيا تم تحييدهم خلال
ليلة واحدة. والسعودية تستعد
لتعوض مجموعة بريكس عن الدول
الغربية وامريكا تلطم على خديها
وروسيا تقف مع حليفتها صربيا
وكويسوفو هي الهدف دول اوروبية
تنشق عن الصف الغربي والزلينسكي
يرفع ورقة الحرب ضد ايران
واردوغان يلقي خطاب النصر متوعدا
امريكا واوروبا وكارثة غير
مألوفة تحل في الجزائر والادارة
الامريكية تستبق الموعد المحدد
وتعلن عن حل لسقف الدين. عملية
الاحماء الروسية. الحرب احالت كل
شيء في اوكرانيا الى الخراب جاب
البلاد من ادناها الى اقصاها.
وبعد كل ذلك روسيا تعلنها نحن لا
زلنا في مرحلة الاحماء فقط. ولم
ندخل الجدة بعد. وها هو وزير
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف
يعلنها قائلا ان الغرب يلعب
بالنار باستعداده للسماح لدول
اخرى بتزويد كييه بمقاتلات اف
ستة عشر. هناك حذرت موسكو من
انها لم تتصرف بجدية كبيرة في
هذه المواجهة. اي ان الروس لم
يبدأوا الحرب بجد وما هذه الا
البداية اذا فكيف ستكون النهاية
يا سادة. لكن الغرب هنا يعترفون
بان مقاتلات اف ستة عشر التي
يجري الاستعداد لامداد اوكرانيا
بها ستكون ضعيفة ولن تصمد امام
الدفاعات الجوية الروسية وذلك
بحسب صحيفة بلومبرج. حيث رجحت
الصحيفة ان تستخدم اوكرانيا هذه
المقاتلات لتعزيز دفاعاتها
الجوية فقط او في العمليات
الخاصة. وهنا الرئيس البلاروسي
الكسندر لوكاشينكو يعزز موسكو
سياسيا قائلا ان العملية الروسية
العسكرية الخاصة كانت حتمية. ولو
لم تبدأ في فبراير الفين واثنين
وعشرين لانطلقت بجميع الاحوال في
وقت لاحق لكن بظروف اسوأ. ليأتي
هنا التأكيد الروسي على ان الحرب
الحقيقية لم تبدأ بعد. حيث زادت
القوات الروسية من شدة ضرباتها
قليلا. وفي ذكرى تأسيسها تعرضت
العاصمة الاوكرانية كييف لاعنف
هجوم بالمسيرات المتفجرة منذ
اندلاع الصراع. ليعيش سكان
العاصمة ليلة مرعبة لم يعيشوها
من قبل. ليؤكد الجيش الاوكراني
تدمير اثنتين وخمسين مسيرة من
اصل اربع وخمسين مسيرة متفجرة
ارسلتها خلال الليل. اسراب
المسيرة الروسية تغزو اجواء كييف
بهجوم ليلي يعد الاكبر منذ بدء
الحرب. فماذا بعد المسيرات ايها
الدب الروسي ليس ذلك فحسب بل ان
الجيش الروسي اعلن تحييده نحو
خمسمائة وخمسة واربعين عسكريا
اوكرانيا واسقاط ثلاثة صواريخ
كروز من طراز البريطاني. ليأتي
الاوكراني على لسان الامين العام
لمجلس الامن القومي بقوله ان
اوكرانيا مستعدة لاطلاق هجومها
المضاد ليعلن البنتاجون ان نحو
اربعمائة جندي اوكراني في
المانيا بدأوا تدريبات على تشغيل
وصيانات دبابات الامريكية. بينما
قالت هيئة الاركان انها سجلت
خمسة وعشرين اشتباكا مع القوات
الروسية خلال الساعات الاخيرة
واصفة الهجمات على ضواحي باخموت
بالفاشلة ومعلنة صد هجمات على
مدينتي. الاوكران يواصلون ردهم
وهذه المرة كشف مقر العمليات في
اقليم كروسنادر الروسي عن محاولة
عدة مسيرات الاقتراب من مصفاة
اليسكي لتكرير النفط في الاقليم.
مضيفا انه تم القضاء عليها دون
الحاق اي ضرر بالمصنع. لننتقل
الى اوروبا. حيث بدأ الغربي
بالانقسام وهنا انضمت اليونان
الى هنجاريا في الامتناع عن
تطبيق حزمة العقوبات الاوروبية
المرتقبة ضد روسيا. فهل تلحق
اليونان بذلك بمركب بوتين كما
فعلت هنجاريا من قبلها? ومن حرب
العقوبات ننتقل الى معارك
الحلفاء. حيث قالت الخارجية
الروسية ان موسكو ستواصل دعم
صربيا في حماية حقوقها وسيادتها
وسلامة اراضيها على ان اي قرار
بشأن كوسوفو يجب ان يكون مقبولا
بالنسبة للصرب ويوافق عليه مجلس
الامن الدولي. لتضيف موسكو انها
تراقب بقلق تدهور الاوضاع في
اقليم كوسوفو فهذا التدهور يهدد
بشكل مباشر امن منطقة البلقان
باكملها. وذلك بحسب وكالة
سبوتنيك. اما الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي من جانبه فقد طرح
على البرلمان الاوكراني قرار
بشأن فرض عقوبات على جمهورية
ايران لمدة خمسين عاما بذريعة
امداد ايران لروسيا بالاسلحة.
وكان الزيلينسكي قد دعا في وقت
سابق السلطات الايرانية الى وقف
دعمها لروسيا. وقال رئيس
المخابرات الاوكرانية كيريل
بودينوف ان اوكرانيا يمكنها
نظريا شن ضربة لتدمير الشركات
التي تنتج طائرات مسيرة في
ايران. لكن مهلا مهلا. هل
اوكرانيا ان تصد الهجمات الروسية
حتى تمتلك القدرة على حرب ايران
يا له من تهديد اوكراني غريب
وعجيب. وبعيدا عن اوكرانيا
وحربها افادت صحيفة فاينانشال
تايمز بان السعودية تجري محادثات
للانضمام الى مصرف التنمية
الجديد التابع لمجموعة بريكس
كعضو جديد فيه. واشارت الصحيفة
الى ان انضمام المملكة العربية
السعودية لهذه المنظم سيعزز
العلاقات بين اعضاء المصرف الذي
انشأته اكبر الاقتصادات الناشئة
في العالم كبديل لمؤسسات بريتيم
وودز بقيادة الغرب. تركيا تزف
عريسها الجديد. اقتراع تركي يبوح
بكل اسراره. لتدخل الانتخابات
الرئاسية التركية التاريخ من
اوسع ابوابه فهي الاولى من نوعها
التي جرت فيها جولة اعادة ثانية.
الجولة الثانية لم تأتي بجديد
حيث حقق المرشح الرئاسي لتحالف
الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان فوزا
صعبا على منافسه مرشح تحالف
الشعب كمال جليشدار اوغلو لتعلن
تركيا اردوغان رئيسا لها حتى عام
الفين وثمانية وعشرين. اما في
الجانب الاخر للانتخابات فظهرت
مشاهد غير مألوفة. حيث وثقت
مقاطع فيديو وصول المنتخبين
الاتراك الى مراكز الاقتراع في
متفرقة في تركيا فبعضهم وصل رفقة
عنزة واخر مع ببغاء للتصويت. في
حين شارك عروسان لحظات من يوم
عرسهما لاختيار الرئيس. الاحداث
والتطورات. اعلن الرئيس الصربي
الكسندر فوتشيتش تنحيه عن رئاسة
الحزب التقدمي الصربي الحاكم
واقترح ان يحل وزير الدفاع محله
في رئاسة الحزب. اسفرت السيول
والفيضانات شهدتها ولايات عدة
شمالي الجزائر نهاية الاسبوع
الماضي عن مقتل طفلين اضافة الى
خسائر مادية كبيرة بسبب تضرر
ابنية ومساحات زراعية وعدد من
موانئ الصيد الصغير. وتعرضت
مدينة فوكا بولاية تيبازا غرب
العاصمة لخسائر مادية كبيرة.
كارثة جعلت الجزائر يعيش في حالة
صعبة. فهل تكون هذه الكارثة اخر
الاحزان للجزائريين تمنى ذلك.
اعلن رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن مكارثي عن توصله لاتفاق
مبدئي مع البيت الابيض بشأن سقف
الدين قبل الموعد النهائي المحدد
من قبل وزارة الخزانة في الخامس
من يونيو حزيران. والذي يتعلق
بعدم قدرة الحكومة على سداد
التزامات الفيدرالية. وقال
مكارثي ان الاتفاق يشمل تخفيضات
تاريخية في الانفاق. مؤكدا انه
لا يتضمن اي زيادة في او برامج
جديدة. عاشت العاصمة الاوكرانية
ليلة لم يسبق لها مثيل بعد تحليق
اسراب المسيرات الروسية فوقها.
فهل تكون هذه الليلة بداية لعهد
جديد من تصعيد الحرب بين موسكو
وكييف?